happening right now local leaders are  hosting a virtual town hall to talk  about covet 19 pandemic related housing  issues  representatives from nevada legal  services the housing assistance  corporation  and clark county officials all together  addressing several issues so here's what  they're talking about  talking about tenant rights how to  respond to a seven  day eviction notice how to get rental  assistance and how to  seal eviction records among many other  topics again this started  just a few minutes ago here at six the  event though is being live streamed on  the clark county facebook page  as well as the clark county youtube  channel